so apple's coming out with a car right
yep this is why i think it's potentially
interesting conversation
i don't think and you should want to
know about this as a tesla owner yeah i
don't think apple comes out with a car
unless they got a better battery than
tesla
the number one issue with tesla
is battery length it's still amazing
if you need a communal car it's amazing
if you're gonna drive around your city
your town whatever
it's absolutely perfect but if you're
someone that gotta
drive long distances
you would prefer a little bit longer
battery life yes
if i drove long distances i would like
for what you do it's literally the
perfect car
it's perfect but for people like let's
say for example you're out there in long
island you're driving into the city
oh yeah maybe most people in the u.s
most people live in like suburbs
and then they drive in yeah you get
caught and you get caught in traffic
you might have an hour in hour out boom
so
but tesla's doing a lot of things to
resolve that problem like they're
offering
crazy discounted prices on solar
paneling like they're like pretty much
replacing
roof panels with solar panels actually
lit so then you could have a charger
at your crib so you never have to worry
and that's renewable energy so it's like
saving the world at the same time no no
what they're doing is absolutely amazing
i'm not being critical of tesla
i'm just saying for apple to get into
the market
i would assume they can't come into the
market with a worse battery yeah they
have to be ready it doesn't have to be
either equivalent as good
or as good now
who is maybe the best in the world at
creating
tons of battery life in small
objects when was the last time you
charged your iphone [ __ ]
last night
but they find a way to squeeze as much
juice out of it
using it 11 hours a day doesn't die
literally yeah
if that's the case i think they're
coming into this game going okay this is
the future electric cars of the future
we're the best at batteries we're
actually better than tesla
batteries he's better at uh engineering
but we're better at battery and at the
end of the day you don't need
a rocket ship car which teslas are you
need an electric car that might take you
450 miles
yeah i think they come into the game and
i think they beat tesla's battery
and then if tesla doesn't come in and
get that
it could affect them this is the best
thing to happen for
customers oh competition yes keep going
because tesla
this is no pressure oh no now they got
pressure yeah before no pressure no
competition everybody's so [ __ ] far
behind us
even like bmw nissan leaf what the [ __ ]
cares bmw's trying to come out with an
electric
tesla already on self-driving so like
we're we're past all y'all we're lapping
you
yep now that apple's coming to the game
elon musk's about to crack the whip on
battery life yo
300 mile range was a big deal before get
that [ __ ] to 500
600 before 2024 because we got to be
ready matter of fact the tesla truck
supposed to have 600
miles of battery life they're gonna have
to hit that now and they're gonna have
to make all their cars get better
because now there's competition and he
will
because he's that dude he's brilliant
he's a brilliant guy but
like you were saying competition is the
best thing for the consumer
yeah we we want apple and tesla to go to
war
over battery life because then we're
gonna be sitting on thousand mile
yeah so battery cars this is for cheap i
can't wait yeah this is this is this is
the best thing but
if you're a non-electric car producer
you should be terrified
oh no everybody's [ __ ] right because
now once when when they were the only
game in town you as gmc you could be
like all right we're just competing with
chevy like
i'm not even worried about that that
they got their little niche thing but
we're not worried about now
oh this is where it's going oh we gotta
get in the game quick
and we're competing with these two
branding geniuses yep
this is what's kind of scary about it if
you're another company you know walmart
killed toys r us
yeah because they would take a loss on
their toys because they know if you're
at walmart buying toys you're going to
buy other [ __ ] ones oh i didn't know
walmart killed toys r us
walmart killed toys r us toys r us was
like yo we're toy stores that's where
you get toys from
toy stores then some specific things
yeah then some company that has nothing
to do with toys is like you know what
we're finna do toys too
that's apple car if you're gm you're
looking at apple like
[ __ ] you guys do [ __ ] phones
how you getting into cars now
hold on this is our thing we're about to
bleed them dry amazon probably have a
[ __ ] car
google already probably working now like
real quick what does tesla have
in their center console it's an ipad
yeah let's be honest about what it is
yeah it's an ipad yeah
imagine you actually had the ipad
imagine your phone is already synced
yeah you get it
it knows all your [ __ ] you got the app
connected to the car it tells you how
far you're driving
you will buy a laptop if you have an
iphone that's apple just because it's
just because it's so see can you imagine
dropping seventy thousand because you're
like that's all apple [ __ ]
if you're gonna drop 70 000 on a tesla
yeah you're like it's the same but
it already goes with all my [ __ ] makes
my life ten percent five percent easier
bruh so ah and low-key i think apple
needs this
i think apple needed a new yeah that's
true because
they haven't had anything hardware yeah
they had
the the airpods which are really good
the the airpod pros are [ __ ] that was
huge i think like for like uh
market share for their business like it
became like a multi-billion dollar
like revenue stream for them just the
airpods yeah and it's to be to be fair i
don't normally
like give apple credit for some reason
i'm just a hater that one though
the other [ __ ] i use when i try to talk
on headphones or whatever nobody can
hear me
this one's always straight
you